two one good morning Millennials and
welcome back to the toast happy
Wednesday it is hump day don't forget to
hump someone you love and I'm sitting
next to someone I love so she better
watch her [__] back damn well we're
twins today so we like you humping
thyself which is something I've
definitely always wanted to explore
today could be the day I didn't realize
we were both matching my it's giving
Carl
we are inspired Thanksgiving no like we
talk mad crap about the mecca Meanwhile
we're just like both sitting here in
outfits that were selected for selected
for you by the people in this room from
a pile of stuff literally we are
literally Annie I just don't feel like I
don't feel like that's why I'm wearing
this today but the facts speak for
themselves so the subconsciousness is
real Jax yeah so we have deer toasters
today and I'm so excited I feel like I
haven't done deer toasters in forever
yeah no it's been a minute yeah and I
think people need my advice people are
really struggling without a hundred
percent without my two cents we had
Sophia last week and then I think the
week before that we had snitch but I was
here on a Wednesday I think it was me I
think I did did do it two weeks ago well
you know what I need to write Dear
toasters because I I have like actually
need to write into unburden yourselves
because quite possibly the most
embarrassing thing happened to me at
Stagecoach that I forgot to tell
everyone yesterday and like I just need
someone to make me feel better about it
well you're talking to the wrong girl
but I know I know you're gonna be
embarrassed of me okay I'll I'll keep an
open mind let me tell you how like
everyone at Stagecoach Stagecoach looked
like Taylor Sheridan the creator of um
Yellowstone who also plays Travis right
the horse Rancher yeah and I thought I
saw him like a few times and then I
actually did see him and I knew he was
going to be there like Yellowstone had
like a big tent at Stagecoach Luke
um Grimes who plays Casey performs he's
a singer so I just had a feeling I was
going to get to meet Taylor Sheridan
like I was just excited and then I
actually did see him like backstage in
like the artist compound it wasn't like
it's very like low-key you know and I
was like oh my God Taylor shared it I
was like so excited I like walked up to
him he had like a big group of people
with him when I tell you I got [__]
body checked by this bodyguard he was
like ma'am no and I was like I was like
oh I was I was like oh okay and I was so
embarrassed he like literally shoved me
and to make matters worse one of the
girls with him who I think worked for
Paramount plus like was a toaster so she
was like turtle and I was like Hey like
can you tell them I'm like not a freak
trying to storm the best deal like kind
of just get like a pic with Taylor and
she was like yeah no I'll work on it and
then I never saw her again and Taylor
walked away and he didn't even look me
in the eyes when he like literally fully
ignored me and I was like Taylor German
and The Bodyguard like literally like
fully chest bumped me and I just like
stood there like a [__] loser being
like Oh okay bye that's not that bad
that's really not that bad no no like it
happens every day to people to have been
there like it was humiliating I'm sure
like you felt
humiliated because like you're kind of a
big star no I just wanted to meet Taylor
Sheridan
like it wasn't even it hurt your ego it
wasn't a star to start I think it was an
ego thing it wasn't a start it wasn't an
S to us you know yeah it was just like
chill like come on you don't like that
there are more famous people here yeah
maybe not since that was the only one
that you you couldn't have been the only
person feeling that way you know who
else I saw and this means nothing too
but it'll mean something to The Toasters
Carrie dubeck
I don't know what his real name is but
remember I was telling you about that
HBO show that I think you would like the
other two with the two kids he plays
like the older gay son who like can't
get arrested in Hollywood he just like
wants to be a star and he was there he
was actually there with Lucy Hale the
whole time I saw him I actually done two
seconds no
you just Admire from afar I admired from
afar I like did want to say hi to Lucy
Hale because like her and I actually
follow each other on Instagram but I was
like really drunk and she had just like
spoken about being sober and I didn't
want to be like sloppy McGee on her
great call yeah it was actually an
acutely self-aware moment for me and
you're nothing if not self-aware nothing
if not so I did like have regrets that I
couldn't get to see Lucy Hale but I
thought it would be best for like both
of our mental health if I just stayed
away yeah for the relationship yeah stay
intact yeah yeah so there's always next
year unfollow right right right but she
fun fact was with Carrie Dubach I wonder
how they know each other
industry you know I know how it is
industry is going to industrize yeah all
right so it's not that bad no not at all
I had to pick the whole day like why
just like the way this bodyguard like
like I was a fugitive like no but that's
like the part of the experience of being
a fan like sometimes it exceeds your
expectations and like you get a picture
and the person so nice and other times
like you get blocked out by a bodyguard
it was just hurtful like honestly I just
think that really has never happened to
you and if not yeah if it has it's been
a really long time you're backstage in
the artist section and you didn't think
it was going to happen like there like
it actually happened
um at the SNL after party that me and
Margo went to for Luke Combs like The
Bodyguard was like No And then Luke was
like Letterman you know Luke really came
to our um our rescue is really kind of
sweet and and chivalrous
um and it was like had potential to be
embarrassing I was like excuse me like
we're friends of Luke yeah I know that
guy was just doing his job so no hard
feelings sir if I ever heard of Yosemite
yeah it's like ever heard of the toast
yeah skedaddle sir but Taylor Sheridan's
um
bodyguard could not be swayed by the
power of the toes I believe that and you
know what we have our limitations I
think that's always good to propel us
yeah and to inspire us and encourage us
to work harder we actually have a lot of
Yellowstone News Today I knew I was just
going to ask you if we do maybe this
will be the episode that somehow gets on
his radar
I don't know it just it was it was hurt
Paul you didn't want to like make a tick
tock being like I met an A-list producer
creator of a show about a ranch rude and
his bodyguard assaulted me
you didn't want to do that yeah like
viral maybe now I do
it's too late no I know because I
already named you I already said who it
was you told the whole story yeah next
time so that's something that happened
to me so it's just been kind of like
weighing heavy on my heart Let It Go
like I didn't do anything wrong you shot
your shot yeah and you missed and that
happened yeah no I wouldn't say I missed
I would say it was honestly Taylor
Sheridan's law it's like I'm a delight
to talk to yeah but sometimes you go up
to a celebrity and like they're just not
in the mood or you can't access them
like it is what it is does it happen to
you
I don't like going up to people I know
even if I saw literally Kelly Clarkson I
had no desire to go up to her yes you
would no you would make me yeah of
course if it was just me I would not
like by yourself yeah it was kind of
like a crazy Rogue I guess maybe I did
look like a little bit of a threat like
I was like kind of drunk and I was like
running around Taylor it's all about
perspective if that was a bodyguard I
think I would have checked me too yeah
okay that was very self-aware of me very
good thank you
um so we've got a ratio we've got deer
toasters we've got like you said some
Yellowstone News some good stories but
before we dive in Jax what's new with
you not too much
not too much recording the redhead today
which I'm really excited about we read
the Magnolia Palace it's about a girl
named LA nolia and
she lives in New York City with her
mother Margot oh I was like well no I'm
kidding it's actually not about a girl
named Magnolia it's about the frick
family and the frick collection cool
Frick I think I don't give a Frick I
don't think actually I was talking to
snitch last time I actually don't think
Magnolia Palace was like the right title
they were kind of like shoehorning the
Magnolia thing in yeah it should have
been called oh frick
love that
freaking awesome
yeah I don't know the context like what
the book is about but like it's
historical fiction it was really good
I'm really excited to record with the
girlies and freaking history next month
is my choice I was literally researching
books last night until like my eyes
hurted it's so so much pressure actually
in my real life book club
um Mike turn is coming up no no yours is
digital I don't know it just felt Shady
really at least you make money from
River Club like I don't know
you're how about okay mine okay
yours is a revenue producing book club
literally well red hex has been pro bono
for many a year right you had to build
you know the audience and the community
before you could really start to
monetize yeah well my turn is coming up
in like a month or two and when I tell
you the pressure is real
because when you choose a book for a
book club you're not choosing like
whatever your next read would be yeah
it's like there's so many different
facets it's like how is this book going
to make me look to other people what are
people going to think of me with this
book what is our book club need where
are the gaps in what we've been reading
so true so true so I feel like I found a
book that will be really fun to read
it's the reviews are saying it's giving
Evelyn Hugo oh and I feel good about it
because I like it and that's all you
needed to say yeah what are you gonna
choose where are you headed so I've been
pretty much set on doing the soul mate
by Sally Hepworth but I know you're
about to read it so it would be helpful
if you could like vet it for me when do
you need to know by I think there's
someone else next and then me oh okay
yeah that's what I'm reading next but I
wasn't going to choose that for the
redheads because I feel like we've been
reading a lot of
we have it and actually like we can't
get arrested in our book club like every
book is worse than the next everyone I
think is like trying too hard you know
yeah
um the last book was just but it was
such a fun book club because we were
just like roasting this book
um it was so bad that it actually made
like some other books look good you know
that can happen so we're in a rut and I
do believe the book that we chose this
month that Margo ashra has been raving
about on the things we left unfinished
or something the things in life that
were left yeah we were unfinished in
which we left them
my friend Margot fish chose it because
Margo austrie raved so hard about it she
raved so hard about it so I mean if
Margo Andre let's Margo fishing Margo
fish will never forget it so hopefully
that'll be good and bring us out of our
rut right but and I do understand how
when it's your turn next you do need to
do something new like definitely not
historical fiction Thriller is always
good
and that's Talia birth and she always
writes a good thriller and I would love
to introduce my girl Sally to my book
club yeah because then they can do
younger wife mother mother-in-law Good
Sister exactly like she has so many good
books and then her you know what
nevermind I'm not gonna finish that
sentence I'll let everyone see their
project kind of like a like a like a
secret project yeah
um and then speaking of books I'm sure
this isn't a story but I only saw this
last night there was some more casting
news in in the end it ends with us yes
movie casting and I don't know why I
didn't get as much hype and you and I
didn't even get to talk about there were
two bits of casting news we reported it
when Margo was on the toast and I was so
excited that guy from 1923. yes did you
watch 1923 no okay well all you need to
know is like he's the hottest man alive
and he's playing Atlas Atlas who's the
pjom boy back home yeah Okay cool so I
thought that was a great casting and
then they just announced that Jenny
slate is playing Alyssa who is ryle's
Sister okay she gives like you know that
quirky friend energy yeah but that's not
like really what Alyssa is like this
really maternal like rational
level-headed CIS who knows her brother
is like the worst yeah but in Hollywood
they just turn it into like a quirky
friend
it's true I think I mean the comments
were [__] brutal and I don't know if
they're really
you can't win when you're casting like a
movie for a book that people love like
they just feel like nothing's gonna be
right so I don't know if the comments
mean anything I just think everyone is
really shocked at how across the board
they're casting much older and the whole
casting to me is kind of a flop yeah
um
so I actually think compared to some of
the other choices like Jenny slate is a
very good choice yeah and I'm kind of
like writing off the movie like I'm
gonna watch it when it comes out because
it's gonna be really exciting I'm
excited for coho and and for the readers
and this is a big moment for all of us
but I'm no longer like as excited as I
once was because it's just doesn't feel
it's not the way I saw it no it's not
how Sue sees it and maybe like the
lesson here is just leave the books to
Reese Witherspoon yeah
yeah except Daisy Jones but this but
these ones was good it was good but
there were some there were a few casting
mistakes just one actually but it wasn't
even that there was something about it
that was like
hmm you know what I mean yeah like it
was very like Free People 70s collection
like not really like so Free People the
costumes were not giving yeah
oh by the way speaking of one person we
forgot to recap at the Miguel in terms
of her look was Cami Marone yes and I
absolutely loved what she wore like it
was she's so everything she's so
everything
she I think she I would have liked
anything she wore because I was just
like happy that she was there and she's
beautiful and can wear anything and I
thought she looked really beautiful
she's an IT girl of the moment right now
yeah she was so good in David Jones I
wonder why Riley Keel wasn't at the
Miguel it's like a year for her yeah
she's Elvis's you know maybe she is busy
maybe she just didn't want to go
respect
um
so yeah that's what I wanted to share
Tyler Sheridan and
it ends with us oh and when I was like
stalking the it ends with us casting I
found that Colleen never followed me on
Instagram I don't know when
wow so now you have to watch what you
say I know I've got so much pressure
except they say mostly flattering things
I've read every single one of her books
like and while this movie like is about
her book it's like I'm not insulting her
no no and I feel like writers I feel
like it must be really hard you know
aside from all the money and the
celebrity and everything accolades as an
artist it's probably really hard to have
your book turned into a movie and like
all the changes that they make and
you're just like it's like there's your
baby and a lot of times like they don't
want the author a part of the project
because the author's so connected to it
and while that sucks I feel like it's
almost better like just you know what
you made your money Take the Money and
Run yeah it's like the last season of
Dynasty Liam's book is being turned into
a movie and they of course it is and
they keep pushing him out and he's
really struggling with that so now I
feel like I can relate to that
experience yeah I watched Dynasty you
know what I'm sure was like hyper
realistic yeah
I don't know it's it's definitely a push
and pull what can I say yeah I mean
maybe we'll write a book one day that
they turn into a movie but that's why I
think Reese is so good at what she does
because like she expects the Integrity
of books and movies and I think she
knows really well like what scenes have
to be in here like what's going to
translate and what's like that's kind of
book things like shut up yeah she's like
so like the book girl that everyone else
should like stop trying
no I think people should keep trying
that way we get more books turned into
movies yeah yeah that's true
they just should get better right should
try harder they should do better
#do better
per usual so we've got a great show I
feel like we could dive in what do you
think I feel as though we could dive
right into the fast five stories that
you need to know
and the fast five stories that you need
to know are brought to you by Noom
Trends and fads come and go especially
when it comes to health and wellness but
Noom is not a fad they use psychology
not Trends to help you make intentional
and sustainable choices that are aligned
with your values and your weight loss
goals whatever those goals are whether
you want to fit into clothes better for
me it was like I just wanted to feel
better like less fatigue less exhaustion
but whatever your reason is Noom is here
for you with their psychology-based
approach Newman Powers you to build more
sustainable habits and behaviors the
program helps you understand the science
behind your eating choices and why you
have cravings everyone's journey is
different so your daily lessons are
personalized to you and your goals
scientific principles like cognitive
behavioral therapy will help you
understand your relationship with food
so whatever your health goals are the
flexible program focuses on progress
instead of perfection so what I really
like about Noom is like if you have an
off day it's not the end of the world
they can account for that it is okay
you'll just get back on track the next
day it's not like you have to derail all
of your progress and just start over
they're very understanding you can
choose your level of support from Noom
so you can get five minute five minute
daily check-ins but you can also get
personal coaching progress is not a
straight line off days are totally okay
they'll just help you get back on track
first time numerous lose an average of
15 pounds after being active in the
program for 16 weeks and 95 of customers
say Noom is a good long-term solution
stop chasing Health Trends and build
sustainable healthy habits with Noom
psychology-based approach sign up for
your trial today at noom.com toast
that's n o o m.com slash toast to sign
up for your trial today and you can
check out their first ever book the new
mindset which is a deep dive into the
psychology of Behavioral change
available to buy now wherever books are
sold today's episode is also brought to
you by droplet if you've been listening
to the toast over the past few weeks and
you've heard us talk about our new skin
care device that we've been loving the
droplet the droplet takes powerful
skincare ingredients and turns them into
fast-moving micro mist and it painlessly
delivers them into your skin why is this
important because your skin works as a
barrier making it incredibly difficult
for the ingredients from your skincare
to like actually penetrate in and I'm
sure a lot of you have done your
skincare before and then like laid in
bed and felt like it's just sitting on
your skin and then it wipes off on your
pillow the droplet device is
groundbreaking technology it is going to
get all those gorgeous important
skincare ingredients into your skin not
onto your skin so something like
collagen which is notoriously too large
for absorption but is critical for
maintaining firm hydrated skin it can
now actually penetrate your skin and
keep it healthy with the droplet the
droplet collagen formula includes other
powerful Powerhouse ingredients such as
peptides airgeline which offer the
lifting effect of injectables without
the needles pain or downtime so it's
really fun device it'll really make a
difference in how your skin care
penetrates in your skin and you will
start to see results within I would say
the first week or two I was like damn
like my skin actually does feel like
it's glowing from within not just this
like layer of sheen on top so for a
limited time listeners can get 20 off
the droplet device at droplet dot IO and
use code toast that's
d-r-o-p-l-e-t-t-e dot i o the code is
chose for 20 off
um and just make sure your skincare is
like really penetrating it's not just
sitting on the the surface of your skin
that's droplet dot IO code toast it's so
important that it penetrates I'm a big
fan of penetration yeah
yeah I mean I guess you are too baby
number two
okay are you ready for our first story
for one and two kind of go hand in hand
because it's Yellowstone first Kevin
Costner's wife Christine has filed for
divorce after 18 years of marriage
according to TMZ she filed to end their
marriage on Monday citing irreconcilable
differences in her filing she asked for
joint custody of their three kids
however she did not ask for spousal
support as TMZ reports that there is a
prenup in place oh damn so
Splitsville for Kevin Costner yeah which
of course you know Hollywood Hollywood
like it's not a big deal for people to
get divorced but this is just coming off
the heels of like a lot of rumors about
Kevin Costner maybe he's like a kind of
a difficult person and now this and he
won't film Yellowstone so maybe he's
been dealing with some personal issues
which is why we literally are never
getting the second half of season five
the timing is us it is us or she's like
you won't go back to Yellowstone I'm
leaving you like you were in my favorite
show honestly relatable yeah and she's
like oh you wanna go back to Yellowstone
I don't even want your scene I love it
you're not going back to Yellowstone I
don't even want your spousal support
that's how disgusting I think you are
for ruining my favorite show right or
their spouse's support is built into
their prenup and there's nothing past
works it's already been settled yeah I
mean while Hollywood marriages are
fickle and you know fleeting and H Kevin
Costner is like no this is like a real
marriage the kids 18 years like this is
like someone's parents getting divorced
so it's not like oh whatever you know
it's sad
um but maybe Kevin's going through
something yeah I don't know if this
pushes him closer to Yellowstone or
further away I'm gonna Venture and say
further away because also was like she
was the one who filed
yeah
but maybe he needs his crew now more
than ever
yeah he needs to get back on the rant or
maybe like being on a show that's so
wholesome and family oriented is like
actually triggering for him maybe or
maybe he's like I'm gonna win you back
and I'm gonna give you the best second
half of season five I've ever seen
that's a very interesting tactic yeah
I think that could work this is yeah
this is sad I hope they get back
together it said it also just seems like
nobody wants to work these days like get
your [__] ass up and go films
Yellowstone season two oh season five
part two yeah it's kind of that's what
Kim was talking about
she was just like a little ahead of her
time she had secret Insider information
about Yellowstone I just watched the
episode of Kardashian season two where
she's getting back last year she's
getting backlash and it's so crazy
because at the time it was like so big
and so loud and like people were taking
you know she said like advice from women
in business I get your [__] ass spin
work like her advice was work hard yeah
you know she said it in like a stricter
tone but she said if you want to be
successful work hard but that was the
message and that that was so
controversial and like the way that
people like took it and they were like
well you know how could you say that
after a year where women are this and
that and it's like she just said work
hard right and that was a like a time
where in in
um the culture you could not talk about
work like if you were talking about like
working from home versus
um back to office if you were talking
about working hard there was like a uh
like I want to say a year where like a
hot button issue was the topic of
working hard versus like working not
hard and remote first office like
remember when Jackie literally like
people were like yeah
that was like a weird time and so what
she said I don't know if we're out of
that time we just like haven't had a
conversation about like work or I don't
want to scare anyone like trigger
warning back to office right you haven't
spoken about those things in a while so
I don't think that the tone really has
changed I just think we haven't it
hasn't come up that was that is and was
if we're in like such a weird thing like
people were so triggered by those
conversations to the point where they
were like canceling people like him for
so what she said like wasn't bad at all
but it was in the context of what we now
know is like the what it's just a weird
time for conversations about work it was
weird yeah yeah but like it was weird to
watch it back with just perspective
because when we say this all the time
like I'll think about someone's like
cancer someone got backlashed or
something and when we're in it even as
us like as Spectators it feels like the
biggest deal in the world and oh my God
I can't believe they did that and then
like you think about it a year or two
later and it's like
it's it's okay like it's it's fine like
someone made a mistake but like it's
okay yeah no I think about that a lot
um with Hannah Brown from The Bachelor
like because she was on Instagram live
and she was singing a song from Tick
Tock that had the n-word in it and she
like mouthed it said it and she like
took a Hiatus and and she shouldn't have
mouthed it we all know like that's not
our word but it was like an accident she
didn't use it as a slurp being like hey
you know right she wasn't used in any
sort of derogatory way she was just
singing a song that she like had heard
so many times on Tick Tock it's honestly
like a mistake that anybody could have
made when you listen to a song so much
and it was so crazy but it was also
coveted right yeah so it was like things
were heightened but when you look back
on it now it's like well she's not a bad
person she just like accidentally said
something she shouldn't have absolutely
saying something right she didn't even
say something saying right saying why
are you saying it like that exactly just
like emphasizing it says singing sang
sing because you know people have issues
with the way I yeah because you're
trying to emphasize saying and you're
still saying sane but that's not their
issue with me their issue with me is
when I say anything that ends in ing it
sounds like that I add a k at the end
okay so say something I'm going to the
store so it's like going yeah actually I
did kind of hear it I'm I'm now under I
used to not be able to understand like
what they're criticism
now I understand it I don't hear it the
way that other people do but I can
acknowledge that it's real well that's
something I dealt with this weekend
everyone was like Claudia and Margo say
Shannon's so weird okay I'm like Shannon
Shannon what yeah no I don't know people
were like nothing Rosemary Shanahan yep
literally people like the northern like
Shannon what else how does Shannon say
it I don't know Shannon
it's giving Rosemary Shanahan and she's
getting into his cleanse Casino
he could stop I don't know if there will
ever be a day where I'll go to a
restaurant and see that they have Clams
Casino and not slam my hands on the
table say hey
just getting into my Clams Casino I
think that you need to try Clams Casino
once I know it's not cool it's not
Kosher we can't and it looks [__]
disgusting but
if you're ever like having a cheat day
fine fine like just I might just order
it so I can like you know what it feels
like and then I'll Ben will get into
yours and so you'll know what it feels
like to have someone getting into your
Clams Casino because I imagine it's
quite devastating
I imagine it's traitorous yeah
I guess we'll never know
how did we get here
how did we get here how'd we get out are
you ready for our next story yeah more
Yellowstone News because when one ship
sinks another one set sail Yellowstone
fans are reeling after two of the stars
are confirming their real life romance I
saw this but they were like too
irrelevant so like who cares they're not
they are but the fact that they are
dating because they date on the show
it's all cute so it's Ryan Bingham and
hassy Harrison you probably don't know
them by their real names but it's the
guy with the guitar who was almost
um killed who was almost killed like
they got him from prison what's his name
um I don't know and the girl who used to
sleep with Lloyd who then went over two
brandy or something she's like a harlot
like she was friends with that brunette
girl who was the [__] worst virgin
who dated Jimmy yeah they were like
these two what do they call them like a
bunny okay their names are Laramie and
Walker Laramie and Walker yeah
um bunny yeah they call them like uh
Rodeo bunnies or you know
is something whatever
um cute like we don't get enough
Yellowstone romance like on set also did
you see I can't remember anyone's name
from Yellowstone I don't know why it's
killing me
um Casey's wife what's her name
Monica is it Monica
Tate's mom yeah I think it's Monica okay
he just feels like that let's just say
for argument's sake her name is Monica
okay she was at the mecca did you see
her no she was snatched like oh my God
so gorgeous yes her name is Monica and
now let's see how she wore this like the
red dress and she has a new short
haircut like it was really
it was working it was giving High
fashion it was giving me Elegance
doesn't she look great oh yeah oh my God
she looks awesome yeah she didn't see
like an Eddie Fanfare for her no she
wasn't in the Vogue article
that's so cool yeah happy for her like
where's rip should be at the Bear's Beth
where's Beth where's Beth and red
they should be there and that's a Miss I
know and like Cole Hauser is married to
like a lovely woman and I have nothing
against her but they're not right for
each other because she's not Beth
yeah but I just feel like in real life
like Cole isn't rip and Beth isn't oh I
actually I don't think Beth is bad yes
Beth is Australian yeah something like
that
um
I think colehauser like you see his
Instagram like it's all about like the
troops and whiskey like he's so Rip but
I also feel like maybe at the beginning
when he was cast like he wasn't ripped
but then like you're playing this guy
and you're like inspired by him and how
do you not fall in love with him and how
do you not want to just become him it's
like well I I could I could dress like
this you know I don't have to go back to
my old hair color no I think even if
it's not like in a physical sort of
aesthetic way that he's leaning into rip
like wearing the coats and the boots I
think in his heart he's definitely like
turned you can't play an actor you I'm
sorry nobody's that good of an actor you
know you can't play a character that
well without it being part of who you
are yeah but I also think like art can
imitate life you could play someone so
amazing that they have a lasting impact
on you completely agree I feel like
people say that all the time usually
they're playing like real life
characters yeah you know I think like
Jessica Chastity was saying that when
she was telling Tammy Faye I mean that
definitely happened to me when I
auditioned for that episode of Law and
Order like I do want to move to
Pensacola it made me want to move to
Pensacola like that character who was a
girl who like facilitated a murder on
the internet because she was just like a
troll who took it too far
um it was inspiring for you it was
inspiring because you know she was
deeply misunderstood you know and I saw
that in the character and that's
probably why I didn't get the role
um and every time that episode airs like
it it's painful for me but I'm so
endlessly inspired
by the character and I think that made
me it's part of who she's definitely got
a little turdy Lou in her you know
she was Dirty Lou she was so dirty
little before he was born no she was
like turning Lou of turdy Lou like had
taken a different route in life like you
know things happen to us and they change
who we are and you could either let it
take you down a dark path and that's
what would have happened that episode of
law order like that's who I would have
become if all the things in my life all
the adversity I faced let me you know I
let it take me down but instead I ended
up here instead you followed the light
yeah and I let it change me for the
better and grow from that so that's
really beautiful it's kind of like that
movie sliding doors like
the girl from Pensacola on that episode
of Law and Order is who I would have
turned into if I didn't get on the train
but I got on the train and here's who I
am now turdy live so you're shame yeah
right all roads back to turn and Luke
100 so you also see speaking of Jessica
Chastain that she dyed her hair yeah
it was cool
yeah
I miss I like the better red well of
course no but sometimes like people do
something crazy I'm like love it yeah no
it was cool for the moment like I don't
think she's in a play so she can't do
you think it was awake no no
um
because redheads I can't really dye
their hair you can't really get your
color back but it did not look like it
would unless her red is not unless she's
not a natural redhead which we've had
this conversation before yeah I believe
that she is but I could also why like
see us being shocked that she's not also
speaking of redheads this is so Random
I'm sure it wasn't picked as a story but
did you see Sophie Turner's thing on
Instagram
so she posted a statement and she was
like I you all know like Joe and I don't
post our kids like we really respect
their privacy
um I accidentally posted a video on my
stories of I think our daughter
um and I'm asking like you not reposted
and publish it on any websites or
whatever I'm sure she was like trying to
maybe post it on close friends or
something and she had posted it for like
a few minutes and it got out there and I
guess like people were sending it around
but you know what I have to say I have
not seen it anywhere not seen it not
heard this story and it's giving me
Faith that's great yeah wow she must
have had such a pit yeah like
accidentally posting on social media
something you didn't want to post is
literally the biggest anxiety-inducing
thing but then having it be your child
level 10. yeah well that's
yeah that
people are respecting it are respecting
it yeah
yeah well anyways happy for this couple
I hope that you know this means like the
set of Yellowstone is
I mean they're like thriving yeah
but like they're not even on set
they're not working I think that they
are you think they're filming the stuff
without Kevin Costner I think that
nobody knows what's going on yeah and I
think that a lot of it is rumors and
gossip maybe that's why Taylor
Sheridan's bodyguard body checked me he
didn't want me to get in the scoop yeah
I think that there's a good chance that
like Yellowstone is hunky-dory and that
everyone just wants to
Trail and even if it's not hunky-dory
it's not like this cluster [__] that
we're all speculating that it is where
like no one can work yeah I think it's
gonna be fine for sure but like where
there's smoke there's fire I don't know
like it's not like they're filming in La
like who's going checking on Montana
what's going on so maybe we should like
and it's the New York Post is the one
who keeps reporting like do you have
boots on the ground in Montana sure good
question
and I don't want if I can hear it such a
good question
so just a little skepticism she said
what she said goes a long way
are you ready for our next story yeah
someone who's really just having a
Renaissance in my eyes this year is
James Corden
I would agree because he's explaining
why he thinks it's time and why it is
time for him to bid goodbye to The Late
Late Show so he did an interview with
Howard Stern on SiriusXM always a great
place to redeem yourself and it wasn't
even about Howard Howard just asked a
question he was like I read a rumor that
you were offered 50 million dollars to
stay in late night like confirm or deny
and James did not deny it and he said
you know like the money it's a lot to
walk away from but that ultimately his
decision
um for terminating his tenure as host
revolves entirely around his family he's
worried about his parents aging and how
little time he has left with them and so
he wants to move back to the UK to be
with them so that like when his dad
calls him up like let's go to lunch he
can just go so that's really why he's
leaving oh my God that's like so that
endears me to him greatly it was like
all about his family and his parents and
just like making the most of the time
that they have left and like no amount
of money could give you time back with
your parents right like
it's priceless oh that's such a
relatable thing I feel like that's the
hardest part about getting older is like
if that's what like me and my friends
are always talking about it's like just
seeing your parents grow older and like
knowing like you have the emotional
intelligence and maturity to be like you
know life is short time is limited it's
like it's so sad and that's honestly I
can't believe James Corden like still
has parents like how [__] old is he
um so so relatable and it's true like
you think how could anyone walk away
from 50 million dollars for your family
you'd walk away from anything like yeah
no and it's like would you pay like you
know I feel like when you ask people
like who have lost loved ones it's like
would you pay any amount of money to
have even one day to get like yeah
together again and they would and like
nothing would be worth like losing that
time but it's not often that someone
like has that perspective I know before
time before it's too late and someone
who's like so successful and like on
this hamster wheel where you could
always be like oh I'll do that then I'll
buy them a house it's fine yeah so to
walk away from all of that I think is
really commendable and I'm sure a part
of him even though this is totally me
it's just kind of like [__] you all like
I think that James Corden is actually a
really good person and I think he had
some you know the Balthazar and the eggs
and I think he was that's another
situation where when at the time it was
like he sent back his eggs
we got so in it like we couldn't see out
and now in hindsight I actually think
that like the whole story was kind of
um
not a lie but like I I don't trust that
Balthazar guy also I like saw a headline
he was talking about
the Balthazar guy was talking about
Adele's carpool karaoke saying that she
looked like Cruella Deville and that
they're both profoundly inauthentic and
called the episode the biggest pile of
horseshit he's seen in 40 years oh so
he's kind of like a Troll he's kind of
like not reputable I just want to be
like with my pitchforks yeah but yet we
all were plant our flag in there so I
feel like between like the petitions to
get James Corden off of movies you know
everybody like ran to like take up their
pitch warts against him because he sent
his wife's eggs back right
um he's like [__] you USA I'm gonna go
be with my parents you know what I feel
that completely and he got into this
it's like the Anne Hathaway circuit like
you're just oh man oh I forgot to tell
you this
when I was at Stagecoach like on during
one of the days where I was just
recovering I watched John mulaney's
comedy special okay it's all about his
intervention
his time at rehab and now like remission
or whatever it's called Uh recovery
recovery thank you
um it was excellent it was hysterical it
was like very he was had been like
extremely humbled and like was really
funny about it
um and something he said that really
stuck with me he was like
you know I relapsed and got divorced and
now my reputation is different and he
said likability is a prison because he
was like this guy everybody just loved
him John Lenny like they really put him
on a pedestal then he just did he did
one thing like he got divorced and I
don't know what the timeline everyone
was like oh but he got divorced like
that's a personal choice in his life
he's allowed to get divorced and now
he's the devil and everyone's like he's
a harlot like and he knows that that's
what people say about him and he was
actually really self-aware and
likability is a prison that's what
happened to James Corden yeah that's
what happened to Anne Hathaway like
likability is a prison Taylor Swift
Taylor Swift people like you
and then they have to it's just like
human nature they have to dislike you
they have to destroy it then you do
something that because you're a person
and not every choice that you're gonna
your make is gonna line up with the like
what people want for you yeah but you
have to do what's best for you and you
upset them and it's just it's so
disappointing and it's a snope like it's
not like they could you disappoint them
and then everyone moves on in fact it's
like well it was that and then they
disappointed me again and they just look
for things likability is a prison I
thought it was like the most profound
thing I'd ever heard that's why we're
free Club because nobody likes us woohoo
and actually the special you should
watch it if you like I know you have
down time it was very funny and very
good he doesn't really talk about the
divorce as much he just referenced the
fact that he got divorced he doesn't
talk about like you know Olivia Olivia
and Anna Marie but he talks all about
his
um intervention like in great detail and
like grave detail about his addiction
like how much what drugs he was doing
how much he was doing how much money he
was spending how he was getting because
the first time he went into recovery he
told his accountant like you're not
allowed to give me money like if
if I ask you for money my doctor has to
be cc'd on the email like his money was
like locked up but he realized he had
this credit card he was using venmo like
it was it was actually just really
interesting like how he outsmarted
himself it's very good and it was just
it was also funny okay okay cool yeah I
watched this stuff before no I'm not a
John Mulaney girl so I just wonder if
it's like funnier than what he was doing
before same amount of funny or like
yeah I don't know I think maybe before I
was never really drawn to him because it
was like everybody loves Jean Milani
generally he's so great I'm like okay
whatever but now he's been like humbled
he's just like the rest of us he makes
mistakes he's not perfect this like
everyone's much more interesting it's
much more interesting when people are
flawed and he was so self-aware like it
was really good I highly recommend it's
called Baby J okay cool thank you for
that you're welcome oh and he was
talking about like he was so nervous
when he got to rehab like everyone was
gonna know him like oh my God it's like
humiliating and not one person
recognized him to the point where he was
like angry about it and he would like
buy newspapers like with his face in it
like leave it across like the facility
he was there for like three months he
was there for a long time that's funny
that's like James Marsden in the one
episode exactly the jury yeah of the
world the world that's what it should
have been called yeah because James
marzin is low-key in 30 Rock
that's who Liz ends up with
it's her boyfriend what's his name Carol
or is that it is right no he's a girl's
name no the other Matt Damon is a girl's
name which team's marsden's name let me
Google it all of her boyfriend said such
[__] weird names
that episode was great James Marsden 30
Rock what is his name
his name was Chris Cross yeah yeah
so good
um
what were you talking about
originally James Corden oh likability is
a prison
um so you know what I agree with you
he's free now and he's like [__] you all
[__] I'm out and I have mad respect for
that not like thank you guys for
accepting me back I'm back okay let me
take my 50 million dollars I'll be back
on TV every night trying to make you
laugh no likeability is a prison so I I
respect him hopefully he'll be at the
coronation this weekend
okay
car nation is this weekend May 6th
snitch's birthday for her birthday she
is getting a King Charles Cavalier
Spaniel hopefully it'll be a beautiful
sunny day in London a spring day yeah
yeah I'm excited for the Fanfare for the
performances for the performances to see
who's there I'm excited I'm gonna like
get swept up why not why not what else
are you doing you can't come to Taylor
Swift yeah might as well get swept up in
a in a global affair right even though
like the camera's coming out for a
global Affair all right all right
that's such a good song
such a good song
I'm really shook because I told you I
wrote I read that short story about
Jessica Simpson and like I've been
thinking about it a lot and like it's
literally about Mark Wahlberg like it is
like the timeline lines up she talking a
little backstory for everyone what
you're referring to Jessica Simpson
wrote like a 30 page book which you
should read because it counts towards
your reading goal and it takes 30
minutes to read and it's good and she's
a great writer and she has cute stories
and it's a true story about
um her dating an actor her like just
like dalliance with her what what does
that mean it like uh it wasn't dating
it's like yeah fling like a short Affair
dalliance all right I'm trying to add
that one to my repertoire is a dalliance
with an actor who she like loved when
she was a like a small child
well not that small but like she was a
fan of his and then she became famous
and like he's A-list then A-list now
A-list back in the day and how they like
got kind of like swept up in each other
he invited her he was filming a movie on
the East Coast he took her with him
um and just like wanted her to like wait
around the hotel room all day to like
[__] or something I don't think they
never had sex
um and then she found out that he was
married that he was in a relationship
all the time so it was just like that's
it right it's about Mark Walton that's
what the internet pretty much decided
like but also
based on everything she said like it's
about Mark well it's crazy that like
it's figured out yeah and it's just like
we're all like we all know Mark Wahlberg
yeah no like there were so many crumbs
that she left like she was at the VMAs
she said he was wearing jeans and a
t-shirt that year he was wearing jeans
and a t-shirt then the movie he was
filming on the East Coast like he had to
get permission from the director to let
her come onto the set because like this
director is known for like um I believe
it was The Departed Martin Scorsese like
this director is known and it was on the
East Coast but it wasn't it was outside
New York City they filmed in Boston like
it was [__] like Jessica Simpson was
on the setup she wasn't even trying to
like not tell us who it was you know
yeah yeah and I just like now that's all
I think about when I see Mark Wahlberg
I gotta read that book because it counts
toward my reading goal you have and I'm
slacking on my reading goal like
literally it will take you 30 minutes
and it's really cute okay
okay
now are you ready for our next story no
because is it the next story that's
brought to you by Athena Club yes it is
Athena club's razor has thousands of
five star reviews and one of them comes
from Yara girl because when I tell you
my legs were so stunning at Stagecoach
this weekend I love my Athena Club razor
I especially love the mount it comes
with it suctions to your
um shower wall and like a lot of
companies say they have that and ask me
how many times I have found my shower
razor on the bottom of the shower like
it's so unsafe it's so what if I stepped
on that no the Athena Club one is
mounted to Perfection the Razer Blade is
also stunning it's surrounded by a water
activated serum that has shea butter and
hyaluronic acid in it and if you know
skin you know hyaluronic acid is so good
for your skin so you get a really clean
shave you get a really gorgeous shave
the best part is that the razor kit is
only ten dollars and it comes with two
blade heads the magnetic hook for the
shower and your choice of handle color
of course I got pink because like my
bathroom was kind of like a rose gold
pink accent to it
um the handle color options are so cute
but they also have black and white
razors if you're a minimalist you want
to get one for your man because Ben uh
keeps using my Razor it's like get the
[__] out of my Razor
um with Athena Club you never have to
think about blade refills because you
choose how often you want the
replacement blades shipped to you for
free and you'll never be stuck with an
overused blade longer than it should be
used for I never like know how long I've
had a razor so then it's just like when
the Athena Club replacement shows up I'm
like oh cool it is time
show your skin the love it deserves with
the Athena Club razor kit head to
athenaclub.com and use code toast for 25
off your first order again that's
athenacub.com use code toast for 25 off
they also launched in Target stores
nationwide so make sure to check out the
Shaving aisle to buy their products in
store in real life they also have other
just great bath time Necessities I love
their um shaving cream their shaving
cream so just head over there get
everything you need today's episode is
also brought to you by Kendra Scott a
leading Lifestyle brand that was founded
on Three core pillars Family Fashion and
philanthropy we all know Kendra she's a
mom herself and she believes motherhood
is full of big events and even bigger
Milestones but it's a small everyday
moments that matter the most so this
Mother's Day let's celebrate every
moment and let women who've made us who
we are as a company who is 96 women
Kendra Scott officially recognizes the
uh Monday after Mother's Day as Mother's
Day Monday and it's an annual
company-wide holiday for all employees
which we love Kendra Scott I feel like
is a core brand here at the toast every
time I've met a toaster I'm like oh I
love your necklace it's Kendra Scott and
now I'm so excited to be partnering with
them we have a code toast that will get
you 20 off uh fashion and semi-fine
jewelry on their website but also in
store and with Mother's Day coming up
for the woman in your life the mother in
your life a friend who's a mom yourself
shower your mother friends in love
there's never a bad time to buy jewelry
but Mother's Day is also just like an
especially good time to buy jewelry
um so now through Mother's day you'll
get 20 off fashion and semi-fine jewelry
when you use code toast at any Kendra
Scott store I think that's so cool and
kendrascott.com that's 20 off fashion
and semi-fine jewelry with code toast I
have a ton of like really cool basic
jewelry pieces like that are really good
for layering I have a ton of like gold
hoops gold chain necklaces that's like
my personal style but they have a bunch
of different styles whatever your style
is but I have like this paper clip
necklace I've got these really cute mini
gold hoops they're really well made it's
you know a brand you can trust
kendrascott.com use code toast um an
order by May 7 to receive in time for
Mother's Day standard exclusions apply
May 7th so the day after Carnation Day
it's Carnation Day are you ready for our
next story yeah just getting hyped up
because Vanderpump Rules is on tonight
and yesterday they dropped the trailer
for the season finale which like I just
need immediately but it was weird
because there was like this turn like
linked trailer going around and I don't
know if it was real or not and then
that's what prompted Bravo to be like oh
you think you saw it here it actually is
oh was it AI I don't know what the [__]
it was there's all this AI now I keep
falling for AI I saw this video I saw
this picture of a pope
and you saw the picture of the Pope and
the puffer jacket everyone was like
stylish Pope I totally thought it was
real that's so funny I also fell for a
cover song of Kanye West singing this is
me trying by Taylor Swift it was so real
I guess you can like it's AI is turned
like it's not to get political but I'm
not here for it no it's really crazy I
think there's like a few cool things
that Pete like uses for and actually
there's probably a lot of like good uses
for it but I think there are a lot of
Nefarious ones I've been seeing a lot of
like
um cyber scams like I saw this woman who
um she got a call like from her daughter
saying Hell like you know that she was
like being kidnapped and like we ran
someone like it's really [__] scary
no I'm not into it I think the the cons
outweigh the pros
um and now I'm just skeptical of
everything I see yeah but I also think
that like some of the AI stuff that I've
seen is like like
I've heard
my voice for AI yeah and it doesn't
sound like me 100 for sure
um I saw this Tick Tock of a guy like
going up to people on the street asking
them what they do for a living and if
they think their jobs could be replaced
by Ai and like pretty much every single
persons could I was thinking that today
do you think our job could be replaced
by Ai No we're so unpredictable we're so
unpredictable and our job is inherently
creative that no I don't no but creative
things can be replaced by AI they're
making like AI van goghs and they look
like Van Gogh yeah that's true like
Picasso no but like our ju like why our
jobs are our jobs is because we are who
we are do you know what that like do you
think AI could become us they could
study us long enough and hard yes yes
they could I don't think I would love to
watch an AI episode of the toast sit
back relax enjoy I actually would too to
be able to finally watch it as like a
spectator yeah and see what they think I
would like what would I say
you know I'm so unpredictable though it
just really depends on how I woke up
like how I slept that night you know I'm
in a good mood but a I wouldn't would
start to study those things and they
wouldn't let's turn it's turn it is
really turn so anyways I guess that
first trailer was AI that you saw I
don't know what it was but that's what
caused them to drop the the real one
okay well in the teaser for the season
10 finale of Vanderpump Rules which was
filmed shortly after scandaval leaked
um the Ariana and Tom have a heated
confrontation with Tom telling Ariana me
and Raquel became like really good
friends she's screaming at him I don't
give a [__] about your [__] about
[__] Markel your friendship is
[__] [__]
um
sheena's crying yep everyone's there
it's crazy how the tone of it which I
didn't expect is like Tom Sandoval like
trying to explain himself not like
grovel yeah but narcissists gonna
narcissist she said I regret ever loving
you obsessed they definitely like cut
stuff right like I feel like we got to
stand a scandavala quickly
no I don't think the finale's next week
no it is yeah
and the reunion is like end of May we're
like almost there
okay no I don't think they cut stuff
we've been watching for a long time I
know I just felt like there was gonna be
so much irrelevant stuff and it's like
actually not and there really are like
traces of Scandal about like the lead up
to this which is why I feel like when
scandabel broke everyone was like it was
the craziest idea ever but it wasn't
like to them it wasn't like they there
were weird but I do think the fact like
there's one thing to be like you behaved
inappropriately and another thing to be
like there yeah but see wait no it does
feel like things have cracked because we
just had sheena's wedding and that was
in August and then I regretted ever
loving you was seven months later
but they weren't filming the entire time
they cameras went back up when school
got it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it does feel like it's coming to like a
natural end oh it feels quick for me I'm
like they oh good they got some stuff
we're enjoying yeah but they said over
and over again they weren't editing the
season yeah well they didn't need to now
that we know what we've seen yeah no
exactly there was traces of Scandal yeah
and the trailer looks really good
obviously there was a big lead up and
it's Kristen Dodie and I just have to
say Kristin Doty is a queen and I'm sure
her just hatred for Tom outweighs
anything but like it really is important
to not forget like how Tom and Ariana
started I do forget like because I think
Ariane is like such a great gal
I and I really feel like it was really
just like one kiss at the Golden Nugget
I like don't see see it as like a
cheating situation but like I'm wrong
for that yeah no it was never they never
admitted that they cheated but like
Kristen was convinced and everything
Kristen like was called crazy for ended
up like being true so but I knew that
already because Tom is horrible right
right so it's like was it really this
big Affair or was it they said their
timeline was totally kosher
I think there was a kiss and there was
definitely like an emotional affair and
like a really deep friendship and he was
kind of like waiting to date her and she
was waiting to date him but to me like
comparing Tom and Ariana's origin to Tom
and Raquel like it's apples and oranges
okay that's how I feel that's how Sue
sees it yeah but I could be wrong for
that well if Sue sees it that way then I
choose to see it that way yeah
um
so Kristin is is filming it's very
exciting for OG Vanderpump Rules fan I
don't think we ever thought we were
gonna see her on TV again yeah suck a
dick Diana
I go around tonight but that that
trailer is not tonight no I think it's
next week no but tonight is going to be
good too they like go on a camping trip
there's all the Fallout from like
um I actually watched so many there were
so many clips that dropped of what's
going to happen tonight they've been
doing this thing Bravo where on social
media they released the first seven
minutes of a highly anticipated episode
to like create hype and it's actually
really smart oh I didn't know that's
what was happening yeah like the first
seven minutes for the last couple
episodes like one minute Clips like
seven of them and I'm like I feel like I
watched the episode right but it's like
Lisa and Ken in their house telling
Katie that Raquel slept at Toms right
then they go on this camping trip you
see Tom try and lie about Raquel having
slept there but Raquel's already told
people because like I guess nothing
really happened that time so she didn't
like she's have anything to hide she's
also like a lot I mean she actually
winds up being a liar because she had a
six month Affair but like whenever she's
asked a question like she's just Aunt
like right so far on the show right it's
like her naivete just answering honestly
yeah
like not seeing how bad it makes her
look right she doesn't like think till I
accept about you know having an affair
and then I think uh what was it someone
said I'm Watch What Happens live like
at one point in this season like Ariana
like goes to Raquel and they have a
conversation about how like Ariana's
worried about her relationship with Tom
and she just confides she thinks he's
cheating on her right I think yeah yeah
and she just confides in and Raquel sits
there
stone-faced that's like true like
mentally psychotic [__] yeah
so we're getting there we're getting
there it's very exciting it feels
rewarding I felt like it would feel like
this endless journey of like watching
irrelevant stuff until we got to
Sandoval no but honestly the season I
have no bad thing to say it's really
every episode has been amazing and
honestly I just caught up on the plane
because last week I didn't get to recap
it
um on the Satchel of it all and I'm
obsessed with it that's Margo's new name
like why is his name Satchel I'm
obsessed with family
it's so weird he looks 11. he looks like
a kid I went to NYU with I'm obsessed
like I didn't think anything could like
make me more excited than like scandival
but all greater than Satchel is every I
could watch the two of them for an
eternity like when she said she was
dating this younger guy like I just
never expected him to look like that and
they're literally perfect for each other
they have to get married the satch the
satch
and I can't wait to like see what he
brings to the show if they really like
become like I always dreams of satchel
oh he better bring a satchel I'm
obsessed and like the hair parted down
the middle it's just it's too much it's
like you that's like your hair okay to
be rude
don't be [__] rude you're wearing
your hair down the middle too much it's
true but like you're committed to the
middle part life okay and you and
Satchel have that in common shut the
[__] up you're such a [__]
I literally didn't even say anything I
say that you wear a middle part like
satchel
move on like just move on before you
really hurt me are you ready for our
fifth and final story yes I am because
we have to dive into your toasters oh
yeah we do and this is just you know our
funny
our funny human interest story of the
day a concert goer at the LA
Philharmonic performance reportedly had
a loud and full body orgasm during I've
heard about this during a performance of
Tchaikovsky's Fifth Symphony it's what
Tchaikovsky would have wanted it is and
the music is like really stunning you
know there are like such freaks like
that who are so into art like they
literally could give himself an orgasm
from just like a symphony I totally
believe this yeah multiple attendees at
Walt Disney Concert Hall reported
hearing a moaning noise at one point
during the performance uh it felt like
there was a gasp in the audience and
rather a lovely expression of somebody
who was so transported that it had some
kind of effect on them a fellow concert
goer described the moment as quite
beautiful when speaking with the LA
Times yeah I happen to think like public
displays of like sex and intimacy are
disgusting but like something about this
is so beautiful like I don't I think I
would start to orgasm with her I'm like
yes Queen like I don't find this gross
at all no I well I just read a quote
that was like a little creepy I saw the
girl after it happened I assumed that
she had an orgasm because she was
heavily breathing and her partner was
smiling and looking at her
okay don't make it disgusting like it
was a nice story until like it was
obviously obviously this girl got finger
banged in the back like her man no but
that's until I read that quote I thought
it was like the music
um and I feel like people don't have
really an appreciation for classical
music these days and I and I I really am
grateful that like this woman to hear
that somebody was brought to a climax
literally because it was deep
appreciation for Tchaikovsky but the
person without boots on the ground
ruined it just being like it was like
two disgusting people like fingering
each other in the back I didn't think it
was that maybe like he could have been
smiling and not have had anything to do
with it maybe he was just like maybe he
also had an orgasm these are two like
classical music aficionados
but they would have reported on his
on his I guess
um sounds
what is like a performance that you
would go to that would move you so
deeply to bring you to a climax
because mine would be Taylor playing
peace May 6 in Nashville
that's why she won't play it yeah of
course what would yours be there's gonna
be kids there I'll be in a suite so I'll
I'll be in the Privacy
um what would mine be like Kelly
Clarkson yeah maybe like
um
maybe like okay I have another one of
what mine would be if I had been in the
audience when Kelly Clarkson performed
piece by piece on American Idol I would
have been brought to tears and climax
that as well that's another thing I
would have yeah yeah totally
[Laughter]
um do you have an answer or no no no I
honestly
but I'm happy for the LA Philharmonic
that they're in the headlines it's a
great reminder you know donate to your
local Philharmonic and you know check
out classical music yeah like it's nice
stuff and who knows what could happen
for you if you go I still sounded it's
true bless you yeah I think it's
actually really good press for
like most last time you supported the
Arts in that way like how to feel a
harmonic or something
not recently because like with covet and
everything you know
there are a few things that I wanted to
see but then you know
what can I say it's not your fault it's
not my fault
um but you know what is your fault
nothing true I was looking for a Segway
So speaking of Segways but other people
who are at fault
are of seven people potentially wrote
into Deer toasters so deer toasters our
weekly advice segment every Wednesday we
try and help the girlies out you can
write into Deer toasters at gmail.com to
get something off your chest if you've
written something in and you haven't
been heard either your uh quandary isn't
interesting or most likely it's too long
so maybe you want to rewrite it and just
like give us just the need to know
Basics we can't be reading you know
mcgillah's again that's deertoesters
gmail.com and dear toasters is brought
to you by the farmer's dog when you look
at bags of dog food all you see is
pictures of bright carrots and juicy
steaks right but you open it up and
you're getting burnt smelly little
pellets dog food needs some fresh
thinking and that's why the farmer's dog
was created it is real food you are
feeding your dog the farmer's dog it is
fresh healthy food with whole meat and
veggies that is gently cooked in human
grade kitchens and they are preserving
the nutritional value of the food
Theo has been on the farmer's dog there
are so many benefits to of course like
the inside stuff you know their bodies
being healthier but some of the things
I've actually noticed is a huge
difference in Theo's breath oh my God
Theo's breath can be so bad sometimes
but feeding him like actual food his
breath is so much better his coat is so
shiny he just has more energy and it
feels good to know like I'm I'm taking
the time to prepare meal for Theo like
one that he deserves you know yeah so
the meals are pre-portioned they arrived
in they arrived and ready to serve packs
they're conveniently delivered on your
schedule and dog people all across the
country have ordered millions of meals
from the farmer's dog it's never been
easier to invest in your dog's health
with fresh food if you've been wanting
to make the switch the farmer's dog is a
brand we highly recommend and you can
get 50 off your first box of fresh
healthy food when you go to the
farmersdog.com toast you'll also get
free shipping when you go to the
farmersdog.com toast
again that's the farmersdog.com toast
for 50 off your first box and free
shipping and you can feel good knowing
like you're giving your stress bro a
healthy delicious meal that they deserve
and then you don't have to smell their
smelly breath anymore which is always
great win-win is a win-win for dogs for
it's a win-win first rice Bros and
Strikes bro mothers stress mothers
should I smitheran mothering all right
are you ready for your toasters yeah
hello Jackson turd my boyfriend a total
pjom just moved into my house a few
months ago we've been together for two
years and I think we'll be getting
engaged very soon he was in the shower
tonight and I went into his man cave to
Snoop to see if he has my engagement
ring yet I should not have done this but
ended I shouldn't have done this but I
ended up peeking into his briefcase to
see if it was in there to my shock I
found a bottle of pills labeled
sildenafil citrates which is a generic
brand of Viagra I was crushed that he
was not honest with me and now I'm
feeling like the recent spiciness of our
sex life has all been a lie what are the
next steps here I'm not sure how to
react but I'm feeling very hurt any
advice is appreciated love you girls a
toaster with a metaphorically flaccid
wiener I don't know evidence that you
found illegally is inadmissible
facts I'm also feeling like maybe just
take the win here you know like
yeah it wasn't great that he wasn't
honest but like accumulating I guess and
it's like at least you're gonna dig down
like just enjoy it you know yeah but
like if you wanted to question everyone
if you're gonna have a future with
someone like you need to know what
medications they're on right I know for
sure for sure but it's like is this one
so bad you know no it's not about it's a
bad medication or it's a good medication
but I think that there should be
transparency no there should and I'm not
saying this is right no I don't think
this is like a this is a horrible deal
breaker like whatever you just need to
find a way to like spill open his
briefcase in the living room and say hey
what's this yeah but I think until you
do that just like enjoy the ride
literally you could be like the lady at
the Philharmonic like at least you're
benefiting from his lie yeah he said
there's been a spiciness oh I guess he
it was under his name so you can't be
like maybe he was picking them up for
his dad right I don't know I heard like
Viagra could be used to treat covid I
did hear that too maybe he's just
suffering from long covet or something
it's happening to millions of you have
to find a way to spell the briefcase
yeah
spill the briefcase and so you guys can
have a conversation about it you need to
like I don't know I'm like not that
annoyed I'm not annoyed but I would want
answers yes hypothetically I would want
answers too but like if I'm the
recipient of the benefit of this drug
what could be bad it's not like he's
taking spermicide you know but it's not
bad it's just
dishonest it's just
have to have information about your
partner for sure for sure
especially two years it's not like it's
a new relationship like those things
take time but like you're talking about
getting engaged like if he has an issue
Ed or something like that's something
that you would want to know about and I
think that that's totally fine yeah but
it's also understandable why I didn't
share it's accumulated no I'm not mad
that he hasn't shared it yet but now my
focus is to get him to share in a legal
way and not saying that you snooped I'm
trying to help you but you could always
just be like hey
I [__] snooped I know it's like
but then it's like okay sure maybe I
take Viagra but like you're a
mistrusting no and then like if he ever
wants to hide something from you again
like he's gonna have to like hide it
better and then you won't find it that's
why you have to just find a way to to
organically like find the the bottle
yeah be okay babe I'm just putting the
sandwich in your briefcase for lunch I'm
putting this sandwich in your briefcase
for lunch or like I bought an extra you
know sub from Jimmy John's let me throw
it in your briefcase what's this I got
these um
perfect snack bars yeah my favorite
podcast was talking about them I think
you would love it as a snack at work I
love that yeah that's the one
um all right next up good morning
Jackson turdy I'm in need of advice my
boyfriend and I moved across the country
this month and moved from a one bedroom
apartment to a three-bedroom home
obviously we're in need of a lot of
things to furnish our new home so far I
have bought everything and it's getting
really pricey I brought up to my
boyfriend that I would like help buying
things for our home but he has yet to
help me or give me any money am I wrong
for asking him to help financially I
appreciate any advice on how I should
handle this no you're not wrong for
asking like two people like it's a dual
income home yeah I know but it's just
frustrating because it's like if if like
she doesn't pay for stuff and he's not
going to then nothing will be bought
right because he'll live in a house with
empty Furniture it's not like a
punishment for him it's right he wanted
it he would work with you to go and get
it I would just get really organized
like start a spreadsheet a checklist
send invoices like this is a it's not
like you're picking up lunch like
Furniture is [__] it's thousands of
dollars also I feel like you need to
find a way to like there are some things
that you guys have have to have right
you have to have a couch a TV a TV a
dining table so like make sure he pays
for those things so that you can pay for
this pant right right this potpourri
Bowl right this sconce this down Comfort
things that he will not pay for because
he doesn't think that you need right but
like he needs a place to sit and eat his
dinner he needs a place to watch the
game he needs a TV and to watch the game
on right so I think that that's a the
best way and your only way of getting
him to help out financially it's like
things that you have to have but just
know like in no way shape or form are
you like irrational or asking for too
much like this is a basic human
necessity and like don't feel shy about
it like ask get the money yeah get the
card just get take a picture of his
credit card it'll just be like an easier
sell if you're like we need a a
reclining chair right not we need this
feather duster this feather duster yeah
this ottoman yeah exactly no but an
ottoman is a basic human right like to
put your feet up
listen you got to talk yeah just think
like a man yeah you gotta act like a
woman but think like a man those were
probably my favorite movies of all time
the Steve Harvey ones oh yeah I love
those movies they're so good the second
one wasn't great but the first was so
good
okay third and final okay what do you
got for us
hey Jackson Claude my boyfriend and I
have recently started looking into
engagement rings after a few years of
dating and living together the other day
after we spent some time looking at
vintage rings he told me that his mom
actually already bought the diamond that
he would use for the ring I had never
heard of anything like that to be
explained further that she bought him
and his siblings each diamonds when they
were born to use for their engagement
now maybe I'd be okay wearing some
mother of the groom purchase ring but
her and I are not very close and she's
always seemed strangely jealous that I'm
dating her son I just find it a little
weird have you heard of this with the
diamond purchasing at Birth apparently
it's a thing in super wealthy families
which I had never heard of anyway I told
my boyfriend I'd rather this just be
between the two of us but he told me
that he feels a little weird not using
the diamond and he isn't sure how he'd
tell his mom that he wants to choose one
just us should I just get over it and
use the diamond even though I wanted a
vintage ring or is this a little odd
one take the diamond neck yes of course
you can reset it into a vintage setting
yeah run with the diamond it's
definitely weird I've never heard of
this the first [__] life and what's
so crazy is like when you give birth
like the first thing you're thinking of
is your son's eventual partner that's
actually like as a mama a boy Mom that's
the last thing we're thinking of you
know it's like that's the we're dreading
it's really weird it's not a thing I
know there are of course diamonds that
are passed down like your grandmothers
like I I know that I never heard of this
[__] this is [__] weird never heard
of this in my life maybe it's a thing
common if you've heard of this but like
I why would your you give birth to
someone your first thing to do is get a
gift for their eventual partner who's
gonna take them away from you no it's
giving some sort of like Hamlet type
[__] like something's weird it's gonna
be an Oedipus take the diamond yeah save
his money and he'll help you buy
furniture yeah of course no no like
never turn down a free Diamond like and
reset it however you like
so you could get a vintage band yeah but
like the stone I guess wouldn't be
vintage who gives a [__] no one thing
she bought it 30 years ago no one so
true by the way
one thing about engagement rings is like
when you're like buying them and
designing them it's like the most
important thing in the world and then it
really is just a piece of jewelry that
you love and associate with your husband
like it's not okay but you're not going
to take away the importance of like an
engagement ring to someone who is
currently getting engaged I just want to
let you know this isn't going to be
something you're thinking about in 10
years being like I wish I got that
vintage you're gonna love it because
it's like a symbol of your love and it
just freed up a couple G's for your mans
yeah it sounds like you also you're
marrying into a wealthy family so I
would just behave you know
you want more diamonds to [__] behave
and take the ring [__] and shut up yeah
no like someone's offering you a free
time and I don't see the problem I'm
seeing Solutions around I'm seeing you
know we could possibly repurpose these
finances to maybe put it down uh deposit
on a home or a car I'm seeing Freedom
Tesla I'm using a Tesla yeah I my advice
is shut up take the ring behave get the
Tesla sure or whatever or a truck I
don't know where you like what do you
what are your needs
now you get to explore those because you
got a ring thank you to everyone who
wrote Into Your toasters again that was
dear toasters gmail.com Our advice
segment for the week tomorrow's episode
we are in studio what
is the segment yeah oh just laughing at
how funny we are I could never
they wouldn't no I think they would
expect me to like laugh a few seconds
after it's over no but they would never
be able to give like such good advice no
because they haven't lived and that's
the thing because we're a really unique
blend of like old conservative Grandma
but like we're also young hip girls we
know these are modern times and things
change times change but there are
Universal truths right and those that
are Eternal some of those Universal
truths like came from your Bubby who
lived in a shuttle like she could never
imagine Life as we know it now
but the principles are they're the same
it's the same yeah and she would take
the diamond and run so and she would
[__] behave
today's episode is over it is tomorrow's
episode is in studio and then Friday's
episode is podcast only because I'm
headed to Nashville to hopefully hear
Taylor sing peace and perhaps have an
orgasm
so thank you so much to everyone
listening to the toast uh you wanna do
it I'm not feeling it yeah but I don't
do it like you is that okay I guess
thank you guys so much for listening to
the toast the best podcast you've ever
heard and AI could [__] never ever
deliver these lines of Comedy genius and
truth if you like us follow us on
Instagram subscribe on YouTube join our
patreon patreon.com so you never have to
go without Jackson turd again and we
shall see you tomorrow
now you say love you bye